yeah okay so welcome everyone to the
last day of the workshop today the first
stop there by our people from Carnegie
Mellon University he's going to talk
about offices all right great thanks
very much it's great to be here actually
I've been hanging out here most of the
semester and it's been great being here
it's a wonderful place at Simons so yeah
so I'm going to talk about learning
about auctions the second part
reconstructing preferences and
mechanisms from opaque transactions and
I'll I'll get to what I mean by that in
a few minutes and this is joint work
with aisha and sewer at Tel Aviv
University and Jamie Morgenstern who is
now at Penn okay so let me just start by
so with first of all a very classic
problem so given random samples of some
function maybe a linear function or a
linear separator try to learn a good
approximation to that function so it's a
very classic type of problem kind of
basically all of supervised machine
learning problems like this ok so now
from there let me talk about a less
classic but still pretty well studied
problem is given random observations of
the actions of some agent presumably is
trying to do something or optimize
something see if you can figure out what
that agent is trying to optimize and
this goes under the heading of and some
in the machine learning world inverse
reinforcement learning if you kind of
model the agent is acting in a Markov
decision process trying to optimize
something and you you're watching is
it's going through various states you're
trying to figure out what what could its
reward function possibly be that would
make it act in such a way and there's
with a lot of nice work on that in the
more economics setting closer to the the
subject of this talk this kind of thing
goes on to the heading of learning from
revealed preferences and the setting
there is your
Ching the purchasing behavior of some
agent whether they buy at different
prices in different markets you're
trying to figure out what they like you
know what are their preference is like
from looking at what they buy okay and
you can imagine that you know companies
like to do this there's been a lot of
nice theoretical work as well on this
okay so what I want to talk about is
kind of a sort of a next level on this
line which is the following type of
setting and then i'll look at some
specific problems in the setting which
is suppose that you don't have access to
the agents in isolation so you don't
actually have you can't just look
directly look at them instead what you
can see is the result of some
multi-agent interaction so the agents go
off into some smoke filled room and then
out comes some things some some are
happy some are not something happened
you just get to see the result of some
multi-agent interactions may be a series
of them and from that you'd like to
extract out reconstruct what the agents
were preferences or needs are in the
setting okay that's the kind of problem
that that I want to talk about okay and
to kind of settings that will be looking
at and I'll get into more specifics what
what exactly I mean here is one from
observing the outcome of a series of
auctions so you're observing just who
won like maybe you go to a web page you
see an ad on that web page so that
advertiser one whatever auction was
going on to show you that ad so you see
a bunch of auction see who won can you
try to reconstruct the preferences of
the agents and this in this case the
agents being the advertisers in the case
when ever add auction or from observing
what which agents end up happy in some
allocation mechanism so here I think
about maybe I jobs being sent off to
some server that doesn't have the
resources to really handle all of them
and so it handle some of them and others
don't get serviced can you reconstruct
both the agent preferences kind of what
resources they needed and the mechanism
so the allocation mechanism that somehow
decided which ones would get service and
which ones wouldn't that's that's the
kind of the problem okay
so just to go now a little more specific
and then I'll go really specific in a
second so here are the two models we
looking at one is a repeated auction in
so the classic Myerson setting so here
you have a bunch of agents each agent is
assumed to have some personal
probability distribution that was that
you don't know and every time something
goes up for auction their their bid
their their value let's say they bid
their value is drawn from that
distribution and they bid that amount so
they bid a random amount from their own
distribution in what is the I see is
some probability distribution over
numbers and so bi is a number drawn from
a distribution if you want ok good so
the problem will be that you don't get
to see the bids if you could see the
bids you could start you could just plot
but the problem is we won't be able to
see the bids we just see who wins the
auction oh and I always always funny
like why would you have a value that you
draw from a distribution why wouldn't
you just have some value for the thing
so the way to think about is that orange
isn't a particular person it's a type of
person it's a type of company or
whatever it's what you can observe and
so that would be a random person of that
type and that distribution would be the
distribution over people that type
that's that's the way to think about it
otherwise I just finds it like why you
know ok so it works general right
deterministic could be but but then yeah
then then this problem becomes boring
yeah so so you can just see who wins
which is not a lot of information but
then you can also participate yourself
let's say we can participate we can bid
you know ten dollars and maybe we win
maybe we don't and we'd like to do is
from there recover the elites the
recoverable part look at what that means
of the distributions okay so that's one
problem the other problem I want to look
at is a setting that in some senses is
more difficult to combat oriole auction
there are multiple items for sale and
bidders have combinatorial preferences
over subsets but it'll be easier and
then we're going to assume agents are
deterministic so we're not going to have
the probabilistic aspect here but we
don't know we don't know what they want
in addition there'll be some allocation
mechanism here that's can't give
everybody everything and so it's going
to somehow allocate things it'll be of a
type that will that will know I'll get
to that in a second but we won't know
exactly what's doing and we're going to
try to figure out both the allocation
mechanism and what the agents want those
are two kinds of problems okay so now
i'm going to i'm gonna start actually
with the second one it's cleaner it's
because deterministic and so now let me
get to what exactly i mean ok so the
setting want to look at is the following
there are n bidders think of them as
jobs and there's one auctioneer it's a
thing as an alligator of resources over
here okay and here's what happens each
day a subset of the bitterest
participate so what's going to be
different from day to day is just which
bidders show up which jobs want service
that day that's the only difference from
day to day the jobs are the same job
that's just which ones actually want to
be serviced each day is different okay
so these three want to be serviced and
what you observe is you know some of
them end up happy and some end up not
happy so some of them you know God God
God service some did that's what you
observe you observe who goes in and you
observe whether they which ones end up
happy and which ones not now what we're
going to assume is what's happening
under the hood here is there are some
resources and each bidder
wants a subset of them so one really
does this one this so one job needs this
this and this another one needs that
that met and what the mechanism is doing
is it has some priority ordering over
them some of them are more important to
it and less and it's going in this
ordering and allocating the resource of
a can if it can't it says sorry I can't
service you and it goes on okay so
that's what we're going to be assuming
and what we're going to try to do is
from there reconstruct the unknowns or
at least be able to predict well when a
new set shows up who's going to be happy
and who's not so let me just say this
again more formally now just to be clear
so we have it's still with the toys but
more formally so we have an bidders or
jobs every day some subset of them shows
up so what's different from day to day
is just which subset shows up there are
M items these are the resources every
bitter in this will look at a few
problems in this one every bidder will
assume as single-minded it's called
single mind what does that mean
single-minded means each one each bidder
or job has a subset a single subset and
they want everything in it in order to
run the job needs all those things so so
the pink one needs that these two the
blue one needs these two the green one
needs these two okay so they have a
single subset they want that that whole
thing what we're going to assume is the
mechanism has some priority ordering
that we don't know over them and then it
just goes in the greedy way goes from
you know top to bottom allocating if it
can so for instance if pink and blue
show up then pink would be happy but
blue would not because pink would get
those two things then the blue needs the
the jack in the box which isn't there
anymore and so blue is unhappy but if
pink and green showed up they could they
would both get service they can okay
what's kind of interesting here there's
a kind of non Mon tenacity so for
instance if blue and green so if green
shows up green get service green and
blue show up not good for green go blue
that's green dozen green blue and pink
show up that's good for green because
blue knock green slightly pink knocked
out blue and so then green got service
so adding somebody could actually help
you because they knock out somebody who
is not
it was ok so what we observe is the set
that shows up and who ends up happy and
who ends up not happy and our goal is to
try to predict correctly what's going to
happen when a new so the bitter shows up
so just to be okay so clear about what
the goals are what's that no we don't
know the resources all we see is the set
the people that show up and who ends up
happy and who doesn't and what do I mean
by predict correctly most of the time
what I mean is there's two that this to
the end possible subsets we just build a
table and we'll make a mistake at most
to the end times but our goal is to make
a mistake at most polynomial and end
times so like maybe N squared mistakes
so over the course of this process
sometimes we'll get it right sometimes
we'll get it wrong we want to bound how
many times we ever get it wrong when
they set what I mean by get it wrong or
right is a set shows up our goal is to
predict who's going to be happy who's
not then we see who was happy was not
did we get it right great doing it wrong
oops were charged a mistake so that's
yep no we don't we just know that there
are these these sets in this in this
problem what to do we have to somehow
right right we'll have to do something
that's right well I look at a few
problems in this one we don't we don't
know that so hello needs a sequence
would you mean number of mistakes oh
good so so every day a subset of people
shows up if it's the same set of
people's yesterday you know exactly
what's going to happen because the same
thing but maybe it'll be a different
thing so just every day there's you know
difference that is the most to the end
really different day as possible but we
want to make a mistake at most
polynomial and many times if you have
values instead of by all the others
okay let's get that okay that's a great
question of what about other mechanisms
and I don't know so so we have a we know
a lot about these these kind of
mechanisms and at the open one of the
open question at the end is you know
what about other kind of mechanism I
will talk about other kind of settings
here though in terms of what the bidders
are doing but it's so here there's no in
this bit model there's no price but you
can imagine that in advance the bidders
paid some amount to like be a
platinum-level gold level silver level
or whatever we just don't know what that
level is or it's some property of the
job that we don't know that's putting
them in some order you can imagine you
can imagine a setting like that where
they pay the mechanism some money and so
they write this other kind of mechanisms
and that would be another right thing
too okay so let's write to get to get a
handle on this let's look at a special
case just to get a feel of this with is
just one item all right there's only one
item just make it simpler everybody
wants it let's also make it simpler that
every day just two people show up okay
so blue and green show up blue gets it
Green doesn't okay now here there's only
n square different things that can
happen so N squared mistakes would be
boring for this problem but could you do
better maybe n log n mistakes okay it
turns out actually n log n you can get
and it's a lower bound and in fact if
you think about it this is a lot like
the inverse to the usual comparison
based sorting problem in comparison
based sorting you pick the pier to
compare the adversary tells you which
ones bigger and your charge one here the
adversary pics which pair to compare you
have to guess which ones bigger and your
charge one if you got it wrong okay in
fact if you think about it the way to
get n log n for this problem is to
simulate the adversary in the usual
sorting lower bound what you want to do
is look at all the N factorial
permutations take away the ones that are
not consistent with the previous
information when blue and green show up
you say look how many say blue is above
grade
how many say greens above blue go with
whichever set is bigger if you make a
mistake you get to cut down by at least
half right now that's not a polynomial
time procedure okay but you can simulate
that in polynomial time by you know
approx by using efficient sampling of
linear extensions of partial orders so
basically we want to do is you can
Impala no meal time randomly sample a
random linear order consistent with this
partial order information so you do it a
few times you say hey on average you
know how many of them had blue above
green or green above blue if blue was
higher and a lot of them you say blue
green and more of them you say green if
they're about the same it doesn't matter
what you say you'll cut out about half
okay so so the usual lower bound for
sorting gives you an algorithm for this
and the usual algum for sorting gives
you a lower bound of n log n for this
problem so the adversary can simulate
merge sort cut ok ok so now let's go
back to the original problem where we
have lots of items now for this one we
will not be able to get n log n will be
able to get N squared and that's a lower
bound ok but we can get it so here so
first of all how are we going to try to
solve this problem well first of all
since we don't see the items let's not
try to learn them instead the only thing
it's really important in this problem is
the overlap of sets okay which one's
conflict with which ones so what we
really just care about is the graph of
of conflicts which sets overlap which
ones ok so so for example in this
picture right pink and green don't
conflict but the rest do so that would
correspond to this graph ok of who
conflicts with whom we get this kind of
this
subsets and you see we don't know the
graph right so we're trying to learn the
graph absolutely just that just this
work rounds right we're going to try to
learn this and we're going to try to
learn this so we don't know the order we
don't know the graph that's something a
higher-dimensional didn't just a graph
um you don't need to so you don't need
to you just need to look at it's just
enough to look at the pair's overlap
that's enough in fact maybe this will
help one way to think about what's going
on is there's some graph sitting here
and one way to think about this problem
is every time step you observe a set s T
which is a subset of the vertices and
then that the ones who end up happy it's
an independent set in this graph in fact
it's a very particular independent set
it's the independence that you would get
if you were running a heuristic of
greedily finding a Maxwell in the pen
set by going in this order okay because
the first guy who shows up on the order
that's in your defense that the next guy
if he has an edge to a previous one you
don't put them in until you get the one
that is independent of the previous ones
in there and you put it in so what you
can think of it as there's a there's a
there's a maximal maximum in the pen set
heuristic they have some ordering or
vertices you see a subset and then
you're seeing the independent set that
that heuristic is producing that's one
way to think about this problem
so to do this here's a way we can we can
solve this problem so first of all since
we don't know anything let's just start
by assuming everybody's in conflict with
everybody this is guaranteed to contain
all the true edges maybe just had some
extra so we're going to maintain that
invariant throughout all so let's start
with all bidders at the top of our
ordering so from now on the ordering
doesn't go left to right anymore it's
going to go top down and these guys are
all the same level at the top okay it's
for all we know they're all the same
what we're going to do is pretty we're
going to predict using our current
conflict graph and arbitrary
linearization of our partial order
meaning that right now is any ordering
will do and then we'll have a several
levels and we'll just kind of our
betrayal in arbitrarily linearize each
each level right so now what happens so
the easy case here is if the correct
answer includes a pair that's connected
by an edge in our graph like maybe these
three show up and pink and yellow win
well according to our graph pink and
yellow shouldn't have both won but so
clearly that edge can't be there so then
we can delete that edge and that's
guaranteed progress we still have this
as a superset of the correct graph great
a harder case is it could be that the
correct answer doesn't include a pair
connected by an edge but nonetheless we
still make a mistake an example might be
like this maybe pink and green show up
we think pink is going to win but really
green one so in that case at least in
this very particular case we can see
look there's no way pink is at the top
if you lose you can't be at the top
because you're at the top you'd always
win whenever you show up so we can
safely demo at least in this case pink
the one level below and what I mean by
safely the mode is not that these guys
are necessarily above pink but just that
nobody's going to ever get the moated
below their true level we know pink
isn't at the top so it could be here
could be below but no one's ever going
to get the mode below their two level
actually what we're simulating here is
what is an online decision list learning
algorithm of helm bold little stone
warmuth that in the decision lyst
setting in and we're simony we're kind
of running that algorithm here okay so
we're going to make that guarantee and
then what you can show and I'm not going
to show you here but it's not too hard
that as long as you do the following you
just look at the first mistake you make
by first mistake I mean you go in the
linearization you were using of you say
what was the first was the first guy
made a mistake on in this two ways that
mistake could be it could be you thought
they get they be happy and they weren't
or the other way around if it turns out
you thought they were happy and you
thought they weren't happy but they
really were then that lets you delete an
edge and the other way around if you
thought they were going to be happy and
they weren't that allows you to push the
guy down and you can prove by in kind of
induction on this that as long as you
only make an up day on the first mistake
you're never going to push anyone below
their correct level and so that gives
you your N squared mistakes because
there's at most n choose two edges to
the leet in this graph and if no one
ever gets pushed below their correct
level the total number of pushes is well
0 + 1 + 2 + 3 up to n minus 1 which is
and other n choose 2 so overall only N
squared mistakes and that turns out to
be optum ok so this is good so this
problem why is it optimal um is easy to
show it's not too hard it's just you
have to if you can give it you can give
a setting where where you know just
information information down
good so let me now switch to a different
setting on the bitter so imagine so I
these toys up for something so imagine
is more like a toy store imagine again
the bidders have subsets of interest but
really what's going on is they just want
one okay so you have to go and buy you
know you just were in Berkeley you have
to go buy a toy for your kid where you
go home and there's a certain subset
that you know might be relevant and
maybe you have some ordering over them
and you're going to go and buy the top
way on that ordering it's in the store
be sure he's just going to sew the same
kind of picture but they're there or is
rather than ann's the videos just want
one thing and when they and they just
want they have some war during which i
haven't shown over the subset that they
care about ok so again the seller has a
priority ordering bitter show up it goes
and that ordering the first guy gets the
top item in their set next guy gets the
top item remaining and their son x got a
top either in there is that if nothing
is left in your set you get nothing and
now for this problem let's say that you
see what each bitter exits with so we
get to see that the pink one got the
jack in the box for instance and the
blue one got the bear if you don't get
to see that then this problem becomes
computationally difficult but let's say
we observe that so we get to see what
the bidders going okay so this is called
unit demand bitter and our goal is to
predict who's going to get what on later
so it turns out one way to solve this is
you can reduce this to the previous case
not so the best way but you can solve it
by reduction in the previous case and
the way you do that is for each bidder
you can create em copies of that one per
item and so so now have a bunch of pairs
a pair is a bitter comma item and let's
say two copies are in conflict with each
other if either they correspond to the
same bitter or they correspond to the
same item and okay in addition to this
if the if the item is not one at all by
the biddy real estates in complicated
everything and now the ordering of
bidders over items together with the
ordering of the mechanism over bidders
creates one big ordering over all these
pairs and now we can run the previous
algorithm and observing who gets what is
observing which of these pairs ended up
happy in which of these pairs end up
unhappy and so we can just do it
directly by reduction to the previous
problem but now we have n times m and so
that's that squared n squared M Squared
mistake stone it's not necessarily the
best thing to do actually a better way
to do this is to combine this list
algorithm with the inverse sorting idea
that we saw before what we can do is we
can have a this this list of bidders
with the partial ordering over bidders
for each bidder we're going to run the
inverse sorting algorithm on guessing
they're ordering over items what we'll
do is the very first mistake we make
will charge it to that bitter and say
hey you you thought blue above you
thought that you thought this thing was
above that thing it's actually other way
around until finally either that the
algorithm you know to make mistakes
anymore or it says wait a second all the
information you gave me is not
consistent with any ordering and we say
oops sorry I guess you're down one more
level so we push you down a level
restart from the begin if you do that
then you'll get the N squared pushes and
the M log M mistakes for the sorting
over the M items and that many mistakes
total here you can prove a lower bound
of NM log M so as a gap of n in terms of
the upper and lower bound but it look
kind of similar except sibu off by a
factor of n okay once you start talking
about settings like this it's also
natural talk about prices so you know so
far the only difference day today is who
shows up and that kadam exciting the
most natural Difference Day a day might
be the prices that things are so I mean
we can hit into getting imagine both so
right so every day as some sets of
bitter shows up maybe it's the same set
and every day there's prices on items
and so who buys was going to depend on
who shows up and what the
Isis are so we can take the same let's
take the same case of unit demand so
every bitter to I mean now so every
bitter has a value on each item which we
don't know and there are prices on the
items which we do see and what the
assumption is the bidder will take the
item that maximizes value minus price so
actually don't have we don't need
subsets anymore it's just if you don't
like it its value zero to you right so
you got values on items maybe you have
value I don't know 12 on this and three
on this and and 92 on this or whatever
yes yes some values on things and you're
going to take your going to compute
value minus price for each thing you'll
take the highest one unless they're all
negative in which case you'll just go
away and not take anything okay that's
that's what the usual unit demand
assumption together with Kwazii
linearity on pump price so your linear
in prices yeah you can also consider the
additive case where people will take
everything of that they want okay but so
so these are standard models and so you
can handle this as well in fact what's
kind of interesting here is you can set
this up as sort of a series of linear
programs so what are we trying to do so
the bigger we're trying to figure out
their value vector so think of like a
let's imagine we have some bound on the
values values between 0 and B so their
vector their value is something inside
this box of 0 to be in M dimensional
space one for every a no object right so
it's something so let's just take you
know a big ol the lips and stick it
around everything to take the middle of
that as our guess is the bidder's value
okay so there's our guests the bidders
value once we have guests is the
bidder's value and the guests are
ordering or some ordering we can now
predict what's going to happen we go
through the ordering and give each one
you know what they would say when we
make a mistake if we can figure out who
to charge it to so if we know okay you
know pink we know you know the top of
our ordering we thought think was going
to get the whatever this is the red card
but really pink got the took the
jack-in-the-box that must be because the
value on the jack-in-the-box minus 10 is
greater than or what
ignore ties or equal to but signor ties
the value on the red car minus 20 that's
why I took this and not that whereas we
thought the other way around so that's
that's like a you know separation Oracle
for the lip for the ellipsoid algorithm
at that point we thought had this thing
better than that but now we just got a
constraint that went the other way
around so we can chop that ellipse and
shrink it and we can basically run the
ellip so we can run a bunch of ellipsoid
algorithms one per bidder every time I
think we look at the top mistake we make
we get a separation Oracle response for
that guy get to shrink is ellipse once
the lips gets shrunk down to nothingness
oops we say oh I guess we have to push
you down we thought you were up here in
the order you're actually somewhere else
restart your algorithm from the
beginning and so we can do that sort of
thing okay so that way so you basically
have is a bunch of these linear programs
but the problem you never know if you're
quite charging the right guy but
eventually you'll figure out that was
the wrong thing you can push them down
and then restart so by doing that we can
we can then bound number mistakes right
so let me ignore the case of the
additive thing so we end up getting is
this many mistakes and squared pushes
down times L where L is a mistake bound
number of separation Oracle queries of a
say the ellipsoid out for any any linear
programming algorithm that you like but
so as you see actually all these kind of
techniques are very specific to the
mechanism that's priority orders there
was a question about other kind of
mechanisms and so here we're we're using
that priority ordering a lot all right
so that's all I want to say about this
setting now I want to switch to the
Bayesian model just say a little bit
about that okay so I want to make the
problem easier now so we're going to
restart fresh problem there's just one
item not a whole bunch of these things
so for there's no list of anything and
it's a standard kind of auctions going
to sell to the highest bidder and let's
let's just I'm going to equate bidders
bids and values so let's say sells the
highest bidder at the second highest
price so that people have an incentive
to you know bid their true value but
we're not going to see the prices anyway
so it doesn't really matter we'll just
assume at the bids and the price and the
values are the same okay so here they
are there's a bunch of people and their
bidding things and the auction
yourselves the highest bidder but we're
going to assume that bidders are
stochastic so getting back to this of
this distributional model every bitter
has their own personal probability
distribution is the orange distribution
the green distribution the magenta
distribution and the Scion distribution
I don't know okay so any we have a bunch
of distributions and at each time T
they're going to bid their bid will be a
random draw from their distribution and
the highest bidder wins and we get to
observe the winner that's what we see we
can also participate ourselves so we can
bid ten dollars maybe we'll win maybe we
don't and our goal is to learn these
distributions okay the setting since
because a bunch of distributions
basically given you know you press the
button you get independent draws
distributions we don't get to see them
you just see the Arg max and you can
tell if you want or not so just to
mention some interesting facets of this
even if you get to see not just who won
but how much they bid so it's like you
press the button you see oh the draw
from distribution three was highest and
I was
d 2 so you get to see that the value as
well it's still not a representative
sample from that distribution because
it's conditioned on them winning right
so just like for instance if every
distribution was uniform 01 sure the
winner will be a random bitter but the
distribution of winning bids is not
going to be uniform and 01 it's going to
be very likely in this tiny range if
there's end bitters and it's not going
to even be uniform here it's going to
slope up right we can just undo the
integral to figure that out in fact
let's define a quantity piece of epsilon
to be the a price such that when you do
this the the chance the winning price is
below there is epsilon so let's just set
some value like for instance in this
case it's very unlikely the winning bid
would be less than I don't know 1 minus
some number over n okay so if you'd ever
SIF the winning bid is never below a
certain value then you're not going to
learn much about the distribution below
there you might learn how much
probability mass is below there but how
its allocated doesn't matter it doesn't
affect anything right so if the winning
bid is never below point nine then you
might say okay half my probability and
as a below point nine but how that i
have is allocated you know I thought I'd
doesn't matter it doesn't affect
anything that you observe so you're only
going to try to be able to learn them
really above that value below that you
just know how much that that's really
all you can get that's why I mean bytes
of the the part you can get your gear
job is to try to figure out what the
distribution looks like above there okay
so there's a really nice tool for
problems like this called the
kaplan-meier estimator which if you
haven't seen it is for the first of a
very cute thing and it comes out of the
medical statistics in 1950s and the
setting is you're doing a study of
survival rates of patients after some
medical procedure but the difficulty is
that patients keep dropping out of the
study and so you know you're trying to
graph how long likely are they to live
five years whatever but some of them
move and whatever they keep dropping out
so what the questions would
okay so that's a good question you're
trying to plot the dropping dead but
they keep believing and so you don't
know how to deal with that okay so when
I say dropping on I mean leaving right
let's use it yeah right so the model
here is let's assume that there is some
probability distribution over survival
rates let's say survival it's always
nice to talk in the positive over
survival rates and and there's a
different distribution over how you know
when people would say leave the study go
off somewhere that's independent of the
first one okay so that you know this on
wescott by the time you were going to
live at some time that you might move to
another city these are independent and
you see whichever happens first okay so
if they're still on the studying and
they kick off then then then you see
that if if they leave you see that they
leave and you don't know how long you
know happily ever after or what okay so
so the goal is to recover the first
distribution don't really care about the
second one and at least up to the point
where nearly everyone has dropped out
all right so at that point you can't
really is no more really date anymore
and the idea is not that complicated the
idea is that you're you're you're always
getting pretty good estimates of the
chance someone servant survives one more
day or one more month given you're still
in the study for instance you start with
a thousand people in the first month two
people died and two people leave so okay
is it two out of a thousand who died or
two of 998 doesn't really matter there's
approximately the same okay and that's
that's the chance of dying in the first
month for the second month you now have
nine hundred ninety six people in the
study you just pretend it starts there
all those 996 some number died some
number leave in that next month it's a
good estimate of out of the 996 what
fraction so you just chain them together
what is the chance of surviving one more
say month given that you are still in
the study at the beginning of the month
okay and so those things and then if you
want to plot this thing you just have to
change these probabilities together the
plot
the curve you want the plot so that's
what they said and if you think about
that's a very much like the auction
setting where if you think about we
observe the bid of the winning bidder
then take a particular video we care
about orange think of XT is oranges bid
and YT is the max of everybody else so
either orange one or orange didn't win
be paying which is higher oranges bid or
the max of everybody else so that's like
the XT and YT and we see whichever is
bigger and and and then we're trying to
figure out this distribution so it
really fits nicely into that setting and
so then you know to apply this than the
issues just well we don't actually see
the winning bid but we can participate
ourselves and so you know we can do is
we can simulate this this mechanism
basically we need to do is we need to
set prices see how often some bitter
beats us at those prices see how that
changes if we change our price a little
bit how much we bid a little bit also
look at how often we win at those prices
and then kind of based on that we can
can estimate how often a bitter bids and
some range given that nobody else bids
above there if you workout it's
relatively straightforward the only is
roughly how often the bitter I wins with
the bid my range given the prices below
that P plus delta which is what
kaplan-meier is looking for and the only
sort of complication here is there are
these errors that keep going up you have
to control them so you don't blow up as
you chained down and does it's a
technical thing to dealing with is it
helpful to view your air is having both
a multiplicative and as if part that
just helps in the induction as you're
trying to prove it the error doesn't
blow up over as you okay you can use
this to also handle the case of subsets
or different numbers of bidders of each
type showing up each day as long as who
shows up on a given day is independent
of the draws the value so it shouldn't
be the case that person to showing up or
not is correlated with the draw of
person ones value from their
distribution okay we need
to be independent okay so now this sort
of also extends to a lot of natural some
extended models so for instance what's a
little funny about this model so far
which even though it's a standard model
is you know shouldn't you have more
value on some things than others I mean
you know this clicker versus the laptop
you know they're sort of different so
you can handle that as well so what you
can model settings were say each item
has a visible feature vector there's
some common component the common value
vector W and the dot product of those
two is of the common value okay so
certain things you know you can model
you know just certain things are
intrinsically more valuable than others
and then we can add on this extra
component on top so your value on some
item is this of common component plus
this sort of noise or individual term
which is coming from your own
distribution and so just if this was
okay so if all the items were the zero
vector it would just reduce back to the
previous problem but you know maybe the
items are kind of different and so you
can handle that as well so you what you
want to do is learn this this common w
so you can subtract it off and reduce it
to the previous problem and then you can
learn the D is okay so okay so let me
now just and so I want to skip over how
to do that could mess okay so just to go
to some open problems I think ok so the
high level picture here is we're trying
to figure out well you know what is it
that you're trying to figure out what
people want from looking at what they do
and but we're looking in a setting where
we don't actually get to observe them in
isolation we can't like really see
exactly what they do all we can see is
they interact and outcome something they
go into this room and outcomes you know
winners losers some legislation or
whatever it is you know you're trying to
figure out who who who wanted what
and from okay so from an auction
perspective I think the first natural
open question which is what asked in the
talk is so this is these are priority
based mechanisms they're nice and clean
can we analyze other natural allocation
mechanisms one nice thing about
priority-based mechanisms if you know
the priority you can run it efficiently
so some mechanisms like vcg have this
annoying property even if you know the
mechanism and you know everything it's
still computationally hard to run it
which is problematic so but but it could
be at their other you know reasonable
mechanisms that are that are efficient
to run and you know we could try you
know for instance maybe something that
involves not strict priorities or
involves bidders somehow you know
bidding for the items and some orders
are various kind of thing so I think
it'd be really interesting to analyze
other kind of natural allocation
mechanisms that could go on you could
also imagine bidders that you know are
unhappy with their status you know they
have silver status which they thought
was good but they didn't realize there's
all these people with gold and platinum
has above and obviously never get
service and so they start you know me
okay it's also be interesting to analyze
other natural classes evaluations also
so the the album's we had weren't aren't
really greatly noise tolerant it'd be
nice to be a add more noise there's this
a technical open question there we have
a factor of n gap in the case of unit
demand bidders of what you can get what
you can show you can't get be don't
really have a good intuition of which
which end is the correct end and in the
second part you know this was has this
nice stochastic component but didn't
have a comet oriole aspect to it so it
was a very simplistic settling of single
items you could you do this in a more
combinatorial setting where you have
valuations over sets of things you know
common situation is like trucking
companies that are bidding on the
ability to send things from different
places if you're going to bid on setting
something for me to be you'd like to
also send something back from beat
a because you your truck just went for
me to be and you want you want to buy
cycles you don't want to buy just path
so so you might have a combinatorial
component to your value of doing various
things and also interesting cases so
what if the mechanism is not truthful
and this is a distribution over there's
a distribution or values and then based
on that the bidders are shading they're
both their their values to get you beds
and so you have to do this mapping from
bits device there's a lot of nice work
actually in this sort of setting jason
hart lion others kind of a lot of work
in the area of econometrics on settings
like
ok